continuing the series where we explore
some of the lesser mentioned deities of
Greek mythology today we'll be taking a
look at iris or as the ancient Greeks
referred to her as Elise the goddess
that many considered to be the
personification of the rainbow V ro iris
played in Greek mythology was similar to
that of Hermes a messenger to the gods
of Olympus she was often seen as the
handmaiden and personal messenger of the
goddess Hera iris was the daughter of
the sea God thalmus a descendant of Gaia
and pontus and her mother was the
oceanic a lecturer in some tellers iris
was married to one of the four seasonal
gods of the wind Zephyrus or Zephyr as
we know him in English and together they
had one child pause one of the gods of
love now there are some conflicting
accounts that believes f-first instead
married Clarisse the goddess of flowers
and greenery to the ancient Greeks who
inhabited the coastal areas the rainbow
was seen to span the entire distance
between cloud and sea they believed that
iris would carry water from the sea to
replenish the clouds and thus called in
rain this in turn led to iris also been
associated of the sky in the sea as well
as the rainbow it's believed that Irish
travel along the rainbow when she was
carrying messages from the gods to
mortal men often being shown and
carrying a jar filled with water from
the river Styx but she would give to
those who were guilty of crimes placing
them into a deep slumber in some other
accounts the jar was used to serve
nectar to the gods the depictions of
iris in ancient Greek artwork are almost
identical to heavy but iris was almost
always seen standing beside Zeus and
Hera there are records that suggests
that iris was the twin sister of the
Titan s our key or art he as she's known
in Greek together they were thought to
symbolize the rainbow the two sisters
were known for their use of the rainbow
when carrying messages but the easiest
way to distinguish between them was
their wings irises wings were golden
Anarchy's iridescent these sisters were
somewhat considered to be mortal enemies
with iris being the messenger to the
gods of Olympus and are key to the
Titans during the war they found
themselves on opposite sides
unfortunately for our ki she
came across rooster in the wall and he
tore her wings from her back rendering
her useless and severing the Titans line
of communication outside of being
described as an errand running goddess
Irish doesn't have much distinct
mythology and doesn't feature in many
stories she was however one of the
goddesses that was present during Leto's
labor of Artemis and Apollo it was iris
who convinced the goddess of childbirth
ilithyia to assist Leto without the
knowledge of Hera iris is role in Greek
mythology as a messenger to the gods is
one that is often overshadowed as it was
Hermes who was considered the
predominant messenger to the gods but
even so she still played a role in the
war between the Titans and the Olympians
the two sisters choose and opposite
sides during the war gives us quite an
interest in dynamic and we can see
ultimately the irises choice was the
correct one it's very hard to dislike
iris because we essentially have another
deity who is more than happy just to
perform their role with minimal fuss and
no drama and after all who doesn't like
a rainbow
I hope you guys enjoyed today's video
and I'd love to hear your thoughts were
you familiar virus before today did you
even know that a goddess of the rainbow
existed in Greek mythology let me know
in the comments below as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained